hey what's up my name is Samuel EADS I'm
a property investor I make a lot of
money in property and I also love to
teach other people how to do the same
things most people that are wealthy they
hide away they don't want to share
anything like I put a post up on Twitter
last night which says ask me anything
and I'll do a video answering your
questions very soon so if you don't
follow me on Twitter man I do say some
crazy stuff on Twitter a show on buying
I published my business plans so head on
down to Samuel underscore leaves and
follow me on Twitter also I really
appreciate you watching my youtube
videos if you watch my videos and you're
not subscribed please do subscribe don't
forget to smash that like button as well
on this week's video Sunday 7:00 p.m.
I'm gonna be answering some random
questions about property on Twitter as
I'm answering these questions if you
have questions if questions pop into
your mind if as I answer you want to
know more just comment all of your
questions below and I do read all the
comments and I try and respond or I'll
shoot a video and respond as often as I
can so comment get commenting below
right now they're commenting below let's
see what we've got so I've watched a lot
of rent tear serviced accommodation
videos and I'm very interested good job
Matt Preston although I don't understand
the basic side fees and what they do
like insurance solicitors associations
limited company etc etc what exactly do
you need to do for it all to be legal
okay so it depends on what the deal is
if you're doing a rent to serviced
accommodation deal serviced
accommodation is a very unregulated
industry so unlike HMOs you don't need a
license to be able to rent out your
property on Airbnb or booking.com
however the things you need to be aware
of is you need to correct contracts so
if you are doing a rent to serviced
accommodation you cannot rent a property
off of a landlord on a normal AST
contract and you become the tenants and
then rent it out because that would be
subletting so instead you need a
management agreement you also need to
make sure that the property has not got
a mortgage on it that has restrictions
on the type of let ability so there are
things to look out for the thing is that
Mac my advice generally to you would be
to just find profitable deals because if
the deals got enough profit in it if you
can find a landlord that's happy for you
to have their property on a rental
service accommodation basis and there's
good margins in it then when it comes
down to the
contracts and the insurance is you just
figure that out because if the deal is
profitable enough that the poly is big
enough for you to give tiny little
slivers to where it might need to go to
so that's my general advice okay what
else have we got mr. Salim have you ever
had a property that has struggled to
find tenants
if so what do you do I've never had a
situation where I've not been able to
get tenants and I think the reason is is
because anywhere will rent out at the
right price you just need to figure out
what the right price is the only time
I've ever not rented out my own
properties everyone I've put rooms on
and the rooms haven't been renting and
about empty rooms and that's always
because either if standard is not high
enough or the price is too high so you
just need to look at the standard of the
accommodation if you get it right if you
do your market research right you won't
have empty and empty properties okay
cloud I have an idea how you can meet
Tony Robbins I will tell you once you
reply
listen I've already switched off man
here's the thing people look like maybe
you want to get my attention or so I've
got this great idea or I can massively
help you I can make you extra millions
of pounds I can introduce you to Tony
Robbins reply and then I'll tell you
just tell me right now man just tell me
in the comment just happen if it's that
good of an idea or guaranteed if I'm
like wow I can make millions off of this
or Wow I can I can meet Tony Robbins by
doing this strategy
listen I'll find you down I'll credit
you or honor you just tell me up front
okay what else
Marc reward lease option agreement where
are these solicitors that can help if
you're buying a house and you're renting
out you can do is pretty much any
solicitors just find someone that speaks
plain English you can just find someone
on Google if you're doing a specialist
kind of agreement whether it be a lease
option or a special joint venture
agreement and you need someone a little
bit more qualified particularly in
property you do need to find the right
solicitor I mean I would happily just
shout out all of my power team but I do
I am careful on YouTube because they
have fun YouTube if I just talk about
who my power team is what happens is
they get so bombarded with phone calls
and and stuff then they're not available
to speak to me so I have to be a little
bit careful about that not being not in
a selfish way or a greedy way any of my
advanced students anyone that pays for
my training courses I give them a whole
Power Team on a plate so you know come
on down to some of the training programs
and stuff like that if you were looking
to build a Power Team
looking to get specialist Lister's and
people like that around what I'd say is
just network go to networking events
attend seminars find people that are
being successful in the property
industry and ask them who they use on
what they're doing hope that helps
poverty course on week end in London
question mark Matty Oh Olivia yes I've
run a lot of property courses there also
and you can check them on the website
I'll put it in the description Josey of
missour I'm trying to find houses or
landlords but couldn't actually there
many houses but to reach them is too
difficult do you know how to find this
just book of Ugandan Joseph there's lots
of houses and also you don't need to go
to a rec to the vendor to book a viewing
on a house you can book you with the
estate agent ultimately some of the best
deals come from estate agents and
there's so many deals out there so if
you find in houses and you think in is
it a good deal is it now shallow view at
Charlotte just pick up the phone and
whoever answers the phone whether they
were an estate agent whether the vendor
whether they deal sorcerer and investor
whoever they are when they answer the
phone just tell them my name is Samuel
whatever your name is
tell them what you're looking for tell
them what kind of a deal you're looking
for you don't even have to ring in a
state agent about a particular house you
can just pick up the phone ring up an
estate agent in your area and say this
is what I'm looking for I'm looking for
motivated sellers that want to sell fast
but are looking to reduce their property
and sell it quickly have you got
anything on your books or I'm looking
for HMO properties where I can I can I
can convert them into hate Jones and get
a really really high return on
investment do you have anything on your
books was that they can say is no the
person that picks up the phone and makes
the most phone calls wins that's my
advice ask man in ten years says do you
need to qualify to be able to afford the
rent for a rent to rent or can you do it
with little income okay you can do a
little income you can do even no income
but if you're doing it through an agent
they might want to see in the same way
if you were a tenant and you were
renting a property they might want us to
just do a little bit of audibility
checks on you depends on the agent but
you can always do it you can always find
a way and if you can't just get a
guarantor George Fontbonne says watching
the financial freedom challenge you've
had a lot of direct contact with the
vendor directly how do you manage to get
so many viewings with just the vendors
and not the agents great question it is
there is a certain power around viewing
a property with the vendor direct and I
think my advice would be a couple things
firstly you can go to a website such as
open rent Gumtree
spare room and you can find landlord's
particular types of animals as well that
by renting or selling the house direct
and you can just pick up the phone call
their mobile number also if your book
interview with an agent and you sense
that the vendor might be in a tricky
situation and it could be like they've
got negative equity and you can do it on
a lease option agreement or you might
want to try and pitch a rent to rent on
them and it's with the agent asked for
the viewing in the evening because
estate agents never want to go out in
the evenings so then if you ask for it
in the evening then they'll probably see
if the vendor can do it direct anyway
folks that's a wrap
I hope you enjoyed it let me know your
questions let me know your comments post
them below or do I'll pick the best ones
I'll answer them next week on Q&A Sunday
subscribe thank you so much for watching
peace out I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]